la force de l'habitude pour la quatrième
fois françois rebsamen s'avançant
vainqueur sous les acclamations de son
camp d'une nouvelle fois il n'y a pas eu
match
les positions du premier tour un peu
resserré ont été confirmées malgré un
entre-deux tours inhabituel et quinze
derniers jours marqué par les violences
urbaines qui lui laisse un goût amer
c'est notre victoire c'est votre
victoire
elle a été construit dans l'adversité
dans une campagne inattendu à prévisible
après nous avons rencontrées face à nous
une coalition une coalition de ce qu'ils
appellent les ténors de la droite tout
petit et nord tout petits avec 43 52%
françois rebsamen arrive largement en
tête près de dix points devant emmanuel
bichot qui fait à peine mieux qu'en 2014
et 20 points de l'écologiste stéphanie
modde à droite on pointe aussi
l'abstention plus de 66%
ce qui nous inquiète c'est deux choses
la première c'est que nous pensons que
ce quatrième mandat et le mandat de trop
et nous sommes inquiets à cet égard
d'autant plus qu'on ne voit pas très
bien à quoi il va ressembler et la
deuxième chose c'est que nous sommes
inquiets sur le fond par la dégradation
de la situation des dijonnais en termes
de qualité de vie et en termes de
sécurité
la majorité municipale sortante pouvait
fêter sa victoire au conseil municipal
elle disposera de 43 sièges sur 59
il y aura une continuité parce qu'il
faut pour relancer la machine maintenant
et sociales économiques
beaucoup de gens ont souffert la crise
il faut faire face à cela beaucoup
d'entreprises et commerces en difficulté
il faut les accompagner
donc dans le goulot nous attend dès
demain aux six mètres
après la mairie françois rebsamen peut
désormais se tourner vers une autre
réélection c'est là la tête de la
métropole